quelques minutes avant l'ouverture des
grilles la tension monte devant le lycée
c'est dans dix minutes on va prier je
stresse un peu normal mais en vrai je
pense que je l'aurais je pense je pense
que je vais avoir le bac peut-être sans
mention mais au moins avec les bacs
avant le bac 9h pile l'équipe
pédagogique affiche les résultats les
lycéens envahissent alors lacunes
des cris des rires la joie se fait
entendre nos lycéens désormais
bacheliers exulte
ses amis
avaient lâché content mais mes amis
l'ont eue là c'est vraiment trop bien
alors qu'est ce que
ça va oui mention bien j'ai bien
travaillé
bah oui oui je sais pas qui c'est quatre
essais nous mais non je suis fière
d'elle
l'a fait en effet sera partagée par le
plus grand nombre bac général
technologique ou professionnel
le taux de réussite et cette année
encore très élevé
89% donc on espère aller à 92 93 94
pourquoi pas 100 donc voilà on compte
sur la solidarité entre les élèves et
puis l'entr'aide pour pouvoir les faire
progresser réussir là deux derniers
chemin après l'émotion la remise du
relevé de notes que deux recalés
quelques élèves admissibles au
rattrapage pour pas de fait pour le
moment ils vont re plancher à partir de
jeudi
qu'est-ce que je